he's a hero Justin Bulma may just be a
kid but he's a follower of Dr Martin
Luther King Jr's lessons a leader who
sacrificed his life to end segregation
Martin Luther
King
taught me that
that you can help anyone in any kind of
way Justin is the CEO of the traveling
toddler and heroes and hearts he's
traveled the world helping build
libraries and places in Africa and even
in Poland during the pandemic the
seven-year-old made care packages for
First Responders and sanitation workers
and for this young life of service
Justin was selected as the Grand Marshal
at Las Vegas's annual MLK parade I'm
trying to think what the word is um
nervous because all the people and being
excited because being the Grand Marshal
King was assassinated on April 4th 1968
in Memphis Justin's mother says that she
instills in her son the values he left
behind MLK said that everyone can be
great
because everyone can serve as a way that
the memory of Dr King continues to live
on even after his life was tragically
cut short regardless if you give your
hamburger to the person experiencing
homelessness on the side of the road or
your Bill Gates giving a million dollars
to make sure somebody has drinking water
in Africa the service is still the same
Joshua peguero eight news now the parade
will start at 10 A.M on 4th Street near
Ogden in downtown Las Vegas the annual
parade honors Dr King's Legacy as a
civil rights leader Good Day Las Vegas
will be live with pre-parade coverage